so what was the Journey of looking for
these giant snakes
of uh looking for anacondas
what are anacondas Anaconda is
the largest snake on earth so you have
reticulated pythons in Southeast Asia
they're actually longer
but anacondas are these massive boas
they give live birth and unlike a lot of
other species so an anaconda starts off
you know a little two foot anaconda just
a little thicker than your finger a
little baby and their food for
cane toads herons crocodiles you name it
they're they're pretty harmless
defenseless
but as they grow they're eating the fish
they're eating the Crocs and then they
grow a little more and they're eating
things like capybara and they're eating
larger prey and then at the end of their
life a female Anaconda you're talking
about a 25 30 foot 300 400 pound snake
with a head bigger than a football and
these things that means that they impact
the entire ecosystem which is very
unique moves up the food chain to become
basically the best Predator yeah
the the apex predator of the rivers and
so that's how interesting is just eating
your way up the food your way up the
food chain if you can survive and like
that you know they're constantly at war
with everything else but
you know so I showed up in the Amazon I
was like so where the anaconda's at and
they were like oh no no it's not like
that they're like it's you you have to
find these things they're they're
Subterranean they're living in the
special swamps they're people kill them
and so we went to the floating Forest
after we'd come back from
an expedition we'd call it like a
12-foot anaconda and it's now it's
become like this like classic photo of
me and JJ with this Anaconda over our
shoulders and we were like we you know
we 12 days out in the jungle on a
hunting trip and we we came back and we
showed his dad and uh Santiago looked at
us and he was like that's the smallest
anaconda I've ever seen he's like you
guys are pathetic oh man 12 foot and he
was like look you go to the go he's like
go he's like I'm giving you permission
go to the boy you'll go to the floating
forest and so we went to this place and
we reached there at night and it was me
JJ and one of his brothers and his
brother took one look at it and was like
I'm out and he started walking back and
me and JJ get to the edge of this thing
and this is our friendship it's both
this two idiots pushing each other
farther and farther and like I like put
a foot on the on the ground and it All
Shook and the stars are reflecting on
the ground and what we realize is that
it's a lake
with floating grass on top of it yeah
and there's islands of grass floating on
this Lake very life of pie and the tops
of trees are coming out of the surface
of the water and so we start walking
across this and JJ's going
these are big anacondas and I'm going JJ
that's a two foot wide smooth path
snaking through the grass there's no
Anaconda that big yeah he was going shh
they're listening I said they don't have
ears because they're listening and it's
like we're walking and we're walking and
then it's like maybe it's like 1am or
something
and it was just like one of those
moments where we saw it at the same time
and we're standing by the tail
and the snake was so big that I mean
this must have been a 25 foot anaconda
dead asleep with a with a probably a 16
foot anaconda like sprawled across her
and they're laying in the Starlight and
we're floating on top of a lake standing
there in the middle of the Amazon and JJ
just I just I could feel the blood drain
out of his face
and as I go however old I was you know
maybe 20 years old I just said if I if
we could somehow
show people this we'll be on the front
cover in National Geographic and we can
protect all the jungle that we want and
so
I tried to catch it
yeah so I jumped on the snake and the
only measurement I have of this animal
is that when I wrapped my arms around it
I couldn't touch my fingers yeah yeah
and so I was you know my my feet were
dragging into her credit this Anaconda
did not turn around and eat me because
her head was you know this bad and and
she went and she reached the edge of the
the Grass Island and she starts plunging
into the dark and so I'm watching the
Stars vibrate as this anaconda's going
and I had to make the choice
of either going head first down into the
black which no thank you or stopping and
just keeping my hand on this thing as it
raced by me and I just felt the scales
and the muscle and the power go by and
then eventually taper down to the tail
until it slipped away into the darkness
and I was laying there just panting
then I turned around and went JJ what
the [__] like where were you man he was
just like completely white circuits
blown and I had to go then like kind of
like take care of him I was like are you
okay and he was like no
you know he just couldn't and so we came
back with that and then after that we
were like okay we have clearly clearly
the parameters of reality that we
thought were possible are are are just a
tiny fraction of what's out there like
we we now that that sort of recalibrated
us we were like okay we're rubbing up
against things that are bigger than we
thought were ever possible and so we
were like okay now we need to we need to
concentrate on this so how dangerous is
that creature to you to to humans to
humans not at all I mean Mike
um what are are Cooks uh father-in-law
was was eaten by an anaconda but like
you know then again like the way you say
that tell that story sometimes it
happens it happens I mean come on every
now and then somebody gets stung by a
bee and dies like you know it's it once
in a while it happens but you gotta have
a really big anaconda really hungry and
like anybody that works in the wild I
mean just you know if you you walk up to
a crocod even a giant Nile crocodile you
walk up to the most of the time they're
gonna run into the water they don't want
confrontation they hunt in their way on
their terms sneaky you're not going to
see him and so with an anaconda it's
like yeah if you're I mean the guy who
got eaten like if you're drunk and you
go to the edge of the water and you go
for a midnight swim by yourself in an
Amazonian Lake I mean whose fault is
that but if you jump on an account and
try to uh yeah try to hold on then
you're safe
um apparently I mean I think I think at
this point we've you know the research
we've done I think I've handled or
caught you know over 80 anacondas in the
field and
um not one of them has bitten me they
always choose flight over fight they're
like just leave me alone let me go I'm
just gonna crawl under this thing
um they're not an aggressive animal I
mean no snake no I actually like I kind
of like the only time I get particular
was like you know the words is like
people go that's an aggressive black
mambas are aggressive no snake is
aggressive a rattlesnake is going to
Rattle to say hey back up Cobra's gonna
stand up and show you its hood and
people go oh look he's being aggressive
no he's not being aggressive he's going
don't step on me don't make me do this
they're actually being very peaceful
that's the way I look at it because if
there's a cobra in the corner of this
room right now he would crawl under the
curtain and we'd never see him again
yeah it's like uh Genghis Khan before
conquering The Villages he always
offered for them to join the Army it
doesn't need to be like this yeah join
us nobody gets destroyed if you want to
be proud and Fight for Your Country then
uh then we're gonna watch him exactly